hallo mein name ist luca und wir spielen
heute irgendein spiel dieses spiel
letztlich circle da oben steht und
trickfilm jeden fall gut wenn man video
anfängt und direkt erst mal nicht reden
kann weil man ein totaler follow hier
liegt noch das essen von gestern unter
tastatur mein bester scorer ist 3 das
sagt glaube ich schon mal aus wie gut
ich das spiel kann aber wir fangen hier
ich bin tot
ihr könnt einfach auf replay klicken und
ihr seht schon ich muss einfach drücken
um hoch zu springen
da habe ich gerade ein highscore reicht
es ihnen jetzt schöner wenn ich als ob
ich nicht über 3,8 ist richtig heiß
also vielleicht liegt daran weil ich in
den händen habe aber sogar hitze ich
gerade schon krass aber na gut wichtig
noch freeplay zocken hier kommen 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 10 11
ich bin ein neuer mensch den ich hoffe
nicht denn jeder dass es in slate oder
und moscow five points single game break
to diamond saddle ich hab doch ich hab
ein ok ok replay zwei diamanten
zusammenbrechen ist jetzt das ziel
da habe ich zwei und jetzt kriege ich
jetzt setzt apple allerdings da zweite
single käme ich hab so hingekriegt mit
jetbird i get that no go
es ist wirklich schwieriger als man
denkt viele sagen jetzt wahrscheinlich
aber das ist doch so jetzt kommen sie
wieder eine scheiß verbogen sie
tatsächlich ganz einfach aus ist er für
mich ein bisschen an dr leber wo man
irgendwie das ding auch so und dann
durfte man nicht die zähne berühren oder
irgendwie so dass deshalb vom prinzip
her so aber es ist echt so schwer man
muss genau aufpassen dass nicht sowas
auf einmal bekomme ich black diamonds in
game
ich habe einfach so 1000 eingesammelt
aber das juckt das game wahrscheinlich
nicht und zwar wollte ich eigentlich
dieses video heute mal so ein bisschen
dazu nutzen ein bisschen zu lagern
über was ganz kurzes eigentlich das
kriegen wir sofort hinter unter so
gleich gehts weiter wird wieder und ich
bin auch dann ich das video seht bin ich
gerade am vorproduzieren für urlaub et
cetera und so weiter und so fort ich
weiß nicht genau wann dieses video
kommen wir allerdings sage ich euch
jetzt schon mal die daten ich bin vom
ich hasse das wenn diese scheiß werbung
immer kommen ich bin vom 28 bis zum
siebten mal vom 28.08 bin ich im urlaub
und dann komme ich halt zum 7 8 zurück
und bin dann halt am 8 auf dem video
days höchstwahrscheinlich es wegen den
ich für die zeit am vorproduzieren das
heißt es könnte sein dass ihr das video
seht irgendwann zwischen den daten das
denke ich allerdings nicht sondern ich
denke soweit sich das video irgendwie
früher nur halt als information dass ihr
wisst okay der dude ist im urlaub das
heißt wenn zwischen derzeit irgendwie
malen video nicht passen kommt dann
wissen wir dass der im urlaub ist und
dass daran liegt 22
einfach mal ne 22 dahin geklatscht wie
geil bin ich denn beim rundlauf fünf die
polen stand da gerade aber was ich
schaff doch nicht mal mehr als 20 fast
ich wollte halt kein extra info video
jetzt machen wo ich bin im urlaub
vielleicht hab ich das sogar trotzdem
gemacht falls ich nicht alles genau
hingekriegt damit vorproduktion ich weiß
nicht aber ich sag's euch jetzt schon
mal hier falls ich keine info video mehr
mache also ich bin im urlaub 27 siebte
bis siebte achte danach auf die video
days danach klausuren und zweitens ford
dessen deswegen sind die videos der zeit
dann wahrscheinlich ein bisschen nicht
aktuell das heißt es könnte sein dass er
bei instagram bild vom ihr seht jetzt
mal rein angenommen dass ich beim
friseur war und ihr denkt euch in den
videos in den fünf - danach höhe der
immer noch lange haare sohn etwa das
heißt dann einfach dass ich die videos
alle vor produziert hatte ich bin
allgemeine dem v produzieren derzeit der
sehr krass also sehr produktiv sage ich
man schaffe derzeit pro tag fünf videos
was der krasses dabei dass ich einem
video zwei stunden sitze aber das läuft
derzeit alles ganz gut und ich bin auch
scott paul oft acht tote insgesamt 50
ach so mein kompletter kanal ist derzeit
nahezu nur noch vor produktion weil ich
quasi einfach mal montag bis donnerstag
in der uni wien freitags ist das video
dann meistens immer wirklich vom tag
selber und dann bin ich samstags und
sonntags meistens im bielefelder so ist
das meistens na ja gut das weiß erstmal
genug gelagert ich bin im urlaub wenn
ihr das video seht ich hab mich ja die
daten genannt und einfach
es ist ok kommen derzeit ich beende das
video direkt wenn ich einmal noch die 22
schaffe weil ich mach das natürlich
nicht so dass ich jetzt jeden versuch
hier mit reinigen sondern schon also
wieder fünf versuche habe wo ich
beispielsweise schon bei der drei sterbe
allerdings das dann natürlich mit
reinnehmen aber jetzt rede ich halte es
wegen den ich das jetzt einfach rein
aber ich möchte einfach nur noch einmal
über die 22 kommen das ist schon ein
lebenstraum von mir seit geburt an habe
ich wirklich dieses ziel das sich
irgendwie über die 22 komme und
dementsprechend meinen enkelkindern
später sagen kann wo ich in meinem spiel
zwei sockel über die 22 gekommen
wir sind über der 22 friends wir sind da
der 22 kann enkelkindern sagen ich kann
meinen kindern sagen wir haben so gott
verdammt viele scheiße 34 4 und 34 läuft
dezent hat beim mann versucht sich echt
immer daran diese kompletten challenges
hinzukriegen
ich weiß ich dass wollen natürlich die
app-entwickler so dass man sich mühe
gibt und das spiel so lange wie möglich
spielt aber ich habe auch jetzt ein
ansporn diese nächste channel zu kriegen
und zwar vier spiele zu spielen was ist
denn rein theoretisch wenn ich jetzt
einfach bei jedem spiel einfach als ob
ich das schaffe so das ist jetzt das
dritte spiel wo ich einfach mal so auf
die schnauze fliege und jetzt replay und
das ist doch jetzt das vierte spiel das
heißt rein theoretisch kriege ich doch
jetzt da habe ich gedacht geschafft hat
meine jetzige challenge ist sieben
punkte in diesem spiel zu schaffen
das heißt sieben ich bin tot und
challenge 9 auch geschafft und die
nächste challenge ist break und game ok
to diamond das ging natürlich selbst
hätten wir schon gleich der erste
diamond und wenn ich jetzt mal ein
bisschen weiter gehe
sehen wir schon am horizont kommt dass
schon der das ist nicht wahr
das war so unfassbar knappe watch sagt
mir zeit aufzustehen stehen sie auf und
bewegen sich eine minute ich nehme
gerade ein video auf ich stehe jetzt
nicht auf aber apple watch weißt du was
ich machen kann
ich kann einfach mal zwei diamanten mir
holen und nämlich sind die da schon
direkt jetzt bin ich tot
und jetzt habe ich einen dino empire die
spielernamen werden immer kreativer ich
hole mir hier gerade so viele diamanten
wie sonst was
aber irgendwie kriege ich diese trophäe
nicht diese challenge ich weiß nicht die
war ja zwei diamonds in einem game das
heißt 12
jetzt habe ich zwei geholt da mal die
challenge die nächste collected audio
software die diamonds ach so tolle ich
habe schon 86 ich glaube das geht immer
von der challenge an los 5%
batterieladezustand auch ein fucking
gold freuen ich muss das video hier bin
ich hab nur noch 53 ladezustand und muss
noch ein video danach aufnehmen ok ich
melde mich hier gerade aus dem schnitt
und zwar wie ich das video gerade zu
ende bearbeitet ich muss allerdings
sagen dass ich mit dem video irgendwie
komplett unzufrieden bin ich wollte das
video eigentlich nutzen um die infos
rüberzubringen dass sich im urlaub bin
und so weiter und so fort was ich auch
getan habe allerdings finde ich diese
komplette story drum rum und wie ich das
geschnittene vollkommen scheiße da
sollten wir den video daumen runter gebt
ich würde mich allerdings trotzdem
daumen hoch freuen den nächsten videos
werden hoffentlich besser ich weiß nicht
irgendwie fand ich das nicht gut kann
auch sein das ist gut findet ich fand es
nicht gut